[Applause]
are we on
[ __ ] awesome
okay
uh david what is your long-term
prognosis for our economy ah wow there's
a generalized softball
or hard ball whatever i don't know uh
what is my long-term pronounces for our
economy um
let's see uh i'm worried about our
economy i mean when you look at when you
look at what's happened to living
standards for something close to the
majority of american people sure they've
really stagnated right and i actually
think that's behind so much of what
we've been talking about here why do
people believe believe crazy stuff right
like the pedophilia stuff
well you know if if if i made less money
than my parents and i was less healthy
than my grandparents and i looked around
my community and it was filled with all
kinds of social problems like opioid
addiction
i'd be pretty angry and i might be
tempted to believe all kinds of bad
stuff because the things that the
experts were telling me didn't really
conform to what was going on in my life
and so i'm looking backwards not
forwards there because the real answer
to the question is no one knows what the
long-term prognosis for the economy is
don't trust anybody but we have new we
have problems we haven't had in a very
long time like inflation yes so and
certainly we have been running up the
debt but not the levels that we have in
recent years where we just sort of went
oh numbers don't mean anything i
remember when uh you know in 08 when we
passed or was it 0-9 when obama first
got in and the the bill to bail out the
economy was like 780 billion dollars and
they were like well we can't go to a
trillion right that would just freak
people out and now they write it like
it's the dinner check right just
i don't know where that leads i don't
know if that's and and i don't know we
are in highly unusual conditions i think
it's worth saying that i mean we're in
the middle of a pandemic um
we're not in the middle of one and it's
no wonder and it's debatable as to
whether we should have lost our [ __ ] to
that degree and there are also people
who say lockdowns didn't really change
anything but i think what i think what
um uh david was getting at was the deep
long-term structural problems in our
economy which president biden was
seriously trying to address and every
other democrat in congress except joe
manchin and kristen cinema uh the one
thing i agree with joe manchin on is if
you don't like me elect more democrats
so i hope that what we have seen will
not depress turnout for 2022 and beyond
because we really need it all of the
things that were in the build back
better bill so many of them were so
popular and so vital i mean the pandemic
revealed just to take one that we have a
child care crisis in this economy i mean
women just hemorrhaged out of the
workforce because they were trying to
raise their kids at home they were
trying to deal with all these issues and
they couldn't take it anymore so we have
that's just one index of many many deep
structural problems that we have that
democrats have tried to deal with and
they're being blocked by this crazy
republican party that's caught between
its rich donors like the kochs and this
inflamed base that believes in
widespread pedophilia but i think i
think it is important to pull out the
lands and look at some of the larger you
know issues that are at stake and i
think david did a really nice job let me
ask you let me ask this it's kind of
anecdotal
but
uh so if the answer is taxing the rich
more yes
i'm going to own up to it i'm rich
i don't feel that bad about it i
appreciate hbo's generosity all these
years so how could it be that like for i
can't remember the last year when i paid
less than half of what i make to the
government i pay more than half
because it's 39 federal and out here 13
and that's without you know fees and
getting solar hooked up and
you know
you know
property billionaire because
billionaires it was just exposed with
the effort to get money
that i could uh they're only paying an
average of eight percent a year while
the rest of us schmoes are paying you
know is that what it is
no it's just a schmuck who pays
my taxes i've slipped from y'all
washington post is excellent
how can i pay so much in taxes and yet
still so much of the country is living
paycheck to paycheck i mean it's the
answer i i don't know how high they can
go
i think the two things are i have no
doubt you're paying a lot in taxes
i mean i wouldn't mind if i didn't also
have this other thing on my shoulders
which is uh so many people are suffering
and i can't even make a living which i
want to help the two things i would say
are one rich people pay a lot less in
taxes as a share of their income than
they used to
than they did in the 50s and 60s and 70s
it's my accountant
no it's the law
it really is and two you said i'm not
married if you look at how rich people
are
because that one's not on the table
if you look at how rich people have done
even after taxes over the last few
generations and not just rich people
upper middle class people as well people
like
university professors and journalists at
national publications
they've done fine
and even after taxes and working-class
people haven't okay
all right uh what are the thought panels
thoughts on elon musk becoming twitter's
single largest shareholder i'm for it
do you think his influence will have a
positive or never negative impact on the
platform
i loved hearing from the the um
employees who had worked with him
under him in previous capacities who
were saying oh my god you know i mean he
has shut down conversations before will
he be able to do this here et cetera i'm
not a big wait wait who's shut down
conversation
elon musk where in his company
it was i don't know again this i think
was this new york times today i'm so you
know you read
i read only respectable publications
sure you read it sounds like it sounds
like you only read publications that you
already agree with
not true that sound
sounds that way
because i read so much conservative
stuff i read all the wackos on the
radical right read my books you will see
that i read their stuff in close detail
yeah
you can't you can give me all the other
stuff you can call me hammerless my
honest reaction to the elon musk news
are we going to have to read donald
trump's tweets again soon that was my
honest that was like my human reaction
which is a tough one because once they
took trump off twitter
things did get better
but but it's not but it's a terrible
it's bad for free speech yeah you know
and and then they're going to go
somewhere and then the resentment and
then the idea that well you know the
people who are ganging up against this
the media and big tech and big
government i mean that's the convoy you
know those convoys and canada and all
over the world people like what are they
so upset about like it's hard to
delve into that but it's some sort of
thing yes
i don't want to get provoke you to use
your second amendment rights on me but
this is one of these moments where i
wish i had my pocket copy of the
constitution because so much of the
discussion of free speech in this
country is not informed by the text of
the first amendment which protects us
from congress from government taking
away our free speech rights but we don't
have to listen to all speech that we
disagree with that's unpleasant that's
obnoxious like when i was a kid like my
mom taught me you know all right who
decides what's obnoxious i could read
this i'm just saying i'm just saying uh
for you a private employer
can fire someone for anything you know
if you don't have a union contract a
private employer can fire you because
they don't like the color of your hair
or the way you smiled or you know what
shirt you were they can fire you for
anything i'm not sure they can do that
anymore but they actually can unless
it's discrimination unless it's been
outlawed by law they can so but my point
is that there's a difference between
government shutting down speech as we're
seeing in these republican controlled
states that are saying don't say don't
say gay you know um
you know teachers can't can't talk about
the truth of american history all of
this stuff that is deeply alarming but
if i decide something's not funny and i
walk away or i think a book is obnoxious
i don't have to buy it like that's my
freedom and their free speech is to say
those things but they don't have a right
to it's just not
of course you don't have to turn on the
tv if there's something you don't like
but that's different i mean and we live
in a different age where twitter is the
market the public square now if you deny
someone's right to speak on twitter
you're basically saying you don't have
free speech rights i mean that's where
it is we're not living in 1980 anymore
this is a different world we live in
where social media controls this so
social media is sort of a
well i mean it's it's living in a space
that's not exactly a publication but
it's not exactly a private company
either
and that's what we have to do it is
that's why it's so tricky yeah because i
mean cbs and abc and nbc and the new
york times the wall street journal
i think they fit the description you
just gave of twitter let's go back 50
years ago right when when those media
dominated the public discussion right
right but they didn't air lies about
election fraud right you couldn't turn
on walter cronkite and hear like
actually barry goldwater won the
election right
like but but that's now what you get on
twitter i understand but twitter also
said you couldn't they banned you
talking about whether
coronavirus came from a lab
and it may well have and even the bite
administration admits that now we don't
know where coronavirus came from but
there's no reason to think it couldn't
have emerged from a lab they had a lab
in wuhan that was studying coronavirus
and you couldn't even discuss this i
think i mean that's outrageous i think i
think that's what elon musk wants to fix
at twitter i think what's tricky is too
there was a context though also of
elderly asians being just randomly
attacked on the street it has nothing to
do with that well the president of the
united states was calling it the china
every virus has been called from the
place it came from i could list you ten
different viruses ebola virus the west
nile virus
murres was middle eastern respiratory
system they were all named from where
they came from and spanish flew nobody
ever gave a [ __ ] suddenly it was about
racism but you agree trump was trump of
course that's trump always makes
everything worse we can't use that as
the standard
to say that we can't
but i mean talk about indoctrination but
i have to say that you can't talk about
whether the virus came from a lab
because it was in asia and that's
somehow anti-asian
racism that's insane to connect to i
don't think i'm saying that either i
think you know
back to your questions
back to balance but but i think i
actually think about there's a common
thread there right which is i think a
lot of liberals saw conservatives
doing really wacky stuff about on covet
right like not taking the vaccine right
and so they're demanding ivermectis
and also lied about ivor mecca and said
it was only a horse medicine and it
wasn't that's also half truth most
liberals would have told you ivermectin
was horse dewormer when it's been
prescribed millions and millions of
times for humans that's what i think i
could never trust anybody because i only
get half the story well that's who
i i think the mistake that liberals are
making here is liberals say they see
conservatives doing something that is
outrageous and wrong and they basically
say well then there's nothing wrong with
us going totally in the other direction
right and i think that's true on both of
these things and i actually think it
ends up hurting progressive ideals right
so yes the racism that asian americans
experienced in this country was
absolutely horrific and donald trump and
members of the republican party fomented
that racism right and they have them
they they are partly responsible for
those attacks on asian americans
calling that out is incredibly important
saying that you can't discuss the lab
leak
hypothesis i don't know
i know you don't i know you don't but
there are definitely that's what twitter
did you can discuss it right that
doesn't do anything to combat asian
american racism right just as wearing a
cloth mask to keep yourself from getting
chin dead doesn't actually protect
people who are immunocompromised and i
just think it's really important that
liberals are supposed to be the people
who believe in science and ideas and i
think they often do just make sure you
keep that theory and you don't decide
that if conservatives are saying it it
has to be wrong and i'm going to go in
the other direction and i'm not talking
to you right
look for truth right we will thank you
very much thank you both early fun
you